brought to you by the order 1886
discover history's darkest secret hey
guys it is the 10th of December today my
name is Jess McCollum and you're tuned
into games buddies president of take-two
interactive cost lattices says that
publishers need to ensure they aren't
milking gamers wallets with dlc flat off
whose company owns GTA developer
Rockstar said that their franchise has
been successful with the elf expansions
because they provide extra continents
that offers real value he called their
implementation of it as quote a
significant strategic asset for us to
keep our consumer engaged with our
franchises in between our major releases
he said that while it is about making
money the most important thing to them
is not to make consumers feel as if
they're being ripped off
splat of also said that it's important
to keep a balance between providing free
and paid extra content this week EAC our
Peter Moore found himself on the
receiving end of some not so pleasant
tweets more reported tweets from one
user that included rape and death
threats toward himself and his family
Twitter then replied that they could
find no fault with the reported abusive
tweets the tweets in question came from
a user whose Twitter bio stated that
more is the one person I want to see
died he since apologized to the EA exec
for his behavior
on a lighter note we got a look at some
images from uncharted 4 that show us
just what the ps4 can do artists and
modelers from Naughty Dog offered up a
behind-the-scenes look at how they built
Drake's new character model during a
PlayStation experience panel you can see
how the character model evolves from
uncharted 3 to 4 where Naughty Dog has
created an older more rugged Nathan
Drake the studio have also worked to
create characters that look and feel
more lifelike Naughty Dog also noted
that there are 850 possible facial
animations for Drake in the upcoming
game
up from just 120 in uncharted 3 that's
your question of the day let me know if
you're impressed by the look of games on
next-gen consoles
if you're often one news you can head to
gain spoke with it's an explanation for
The Witcher 3 delay and sorry talks
straight out of 5 exclusivity that is it
for me today I'll be back tomorrow with
a bunch more news and be sure to have
yourself a good one until then